all right so Yellow Jackets season two
is kicked off winter has come and flesh
is finally on the menu I was personally
mystified by season one's roller coaster
of Supernatural twists and turns and I
am hungry for more so in this video
we're going to be breaking this thing
down the latest episode of season two
things you might have missed some
callbacks and potential theories to
explain some of these weird symbols and
events that are happening now this recap
is going to be heavy on the spoilers so
if you haven't kicked off season two yet
then get out of here if you enjoy this
video though hit that like button as
it's much appreciated and subscribe to
join the Beehive of spoilers as we'll be
covering this weekly with all of that
out of the way thank you for clicking
this I'm your host Jared now let's get
into Yellow Jackets now season two kicks
off roughly two months after Jackie was
turned into a human popsicle and left
Shauna and the others completely dead
devastated in the wilderness as winter
was upon them here we get Snippets of
the cabin living arrangements and daily
routine with Sharon Von Eaton's 17 being
the backtrack to all of this several of
the girls are camped out downstairs to
stay warm by the fire while taisa and
Van appear to have their relationship
continuing their wrists are tied
together with some rope which we later
find out is Van's remedy for taisha's
sleepwalking climbing and dirt eating
instances coach Scott is full on
Lumberjack beard mode and Shauna is
sleeping next to an empty bunk that we
can assume is Jackie's it looks like
everyone has sort of adapted a routine
as Travis and Natalie gear up for their
morning hunt insulating their socks and
jackets with the nudie magazines that
they found in the cabin during season
one Lottie leaning into her Supernatural
rituals sends them on their way but not
before rubbing ashes on their palms
blessing them with some makeshift
incense and and drinking some herbal tea
with a drop of lottie's blood in it
obviously after lottie's baptism from
Laura Lee she has slowly become more and
more religious in her beliefs and these
same practices are usually done in
churches for example ashes for Catholic
Ash Wednesday I love Natalie's
skepticism of Lottie calling it Wicca
essentially the modern interpretation of
pagan worship and Witchcraft but Lottie
rebuttals with the age-old fear tactic
why you keep coming back alive don't you
which is utilized by several religions
and groups we see her draw the same
mysterious cryptic a symbol we've seen
time and time again in season one
obviously Lottie is adapting this more
and more but its true meaning has
honestly yet to be revealed I mean some
theories out there suggest it's an
upside down person hanging from a hook
and about to bleed out but again only a
Theory flash forward to 1998 as the
surviving girls appear to board a plane
and fly back to New Jersey wearing
search and rescue sweatshirts the scene
is honestly crafted really well because
we don't actually get to see who made it
out alive and who didn't I mean aside
from the four women from season one and
I'm assuming Lottie it looks like van
may have survived too with one of the
girls having red hair now subtle Clues
as to what happened with their flight
also are revealed with one reporter
stating that the crash site was roughly
600 miles north of the anticipated
flight path Nationals were supposed to
be in Seattle which is where they're at
according to the patches on the police
officers uniforms so 600 miles north of
a New Jersey to Seattle flight path puts
them well over the Canadian border which
explains why no one found them Lottie is
put through electroshock therapy by her
parents this is done because of her
Wilderness PTSD while her father never
believed in her quote psychic abilities
so I think from his point of view this
is much needed procedure during this
though Lottie has the same Visions from
her baptism but appear to be fading the
candle is slowly extinguishing meaning
maybe a Lottie is losing faith in what
Laura Lee had preached to her as it then
flashes to present day and yes Lottie is
very much alive and just like the final
episode of season one hinted at it
appears she is running a cult like
straight up Scientology and Nexium style
as she preaches about bettering
themselves and the perfect vision of you
is out there one line though stood out
to me because it is
it isn't real part of me thinks Lottie
just compartmentalized the Wilderness
and it's not real to her anyway the
coloring of the clothing gives us a bit
of an insight into where Lottie stands
in comparison to her followers first
they are all wearing light pastel purple
invoking spirituality and Imagination
this is also what the gang was wearing
when they kidnapped Natalie so
suspicions are correct Lottie was behind
it while Lottie is wearing an orange or
burnt sienna for anyone who could afford
those 64 crayon sets as a child now
orange typically provides warmth and
emotional support as she is supporting
her followers finally the standard
Yellow Jackets intro kicks in however
this is updated with new footage from
season two these are quick shots but may
give us a clue as to what to expect in
this season we see who looks like coach
Scott putting on a facial mask probably
some much needed backstory on his
character a close-up of the pendants a
lot he's followers are wearing and her
preaching a note with I am grateful for
my friends written on it followed by
someone burning this maybe betrayal
during this or after the Wilderness a
low angle shot of 10 girls as opposed to
only four in the season 1 intro so maybe
season two is focusing on much more of
the yellow jackets a shot of an older
van so we know that she's gotten out of
there at some point what looks like a
Captain America Civil War Twilight
Breaking Dawn Showdown with half of the
girls having weapons getting ready for
some cat fights baby and of course no
eyes man from season one again makes an
appearance who or what are you I hope we
find out it looks like present day picks
up right where we left off with Misty
trying to train Shauna how to dupe the
police if they ever question her about
Adam's disappearance I'm sorry but Misty
it Misty is weird but the I want my
lawyer cookie cake was great even though
the women went through all of this
together in the last season it didn't
necessarily ignite their friendship as
Tasia and Natalie are over an hour late
for Misty's murder masterclass Shauna
reassures her everything is going to be
fine while Misty thinks they might have
missed something Misty's been trying to
contact Natalie almost every hour on the
hour without any answer so she checks
out her trusty citizen detective
subreddit for tips there are a lot of
small details tucked away here first
Misty's username being African gray
tying back to our bird Caligula which is
also likely named after the Roman
Emperor who was a bit off of his rocker
if so this is some subtle character
development on Misty if you didn't know
but a couple of topics being discussed
tie back to season one events the
Parsippany poisoner what are the cops
missing is most likely referring to miss
SD poisoning Jessica at the end of
season one because Parsippany is a
Township located in New Jersey and
that's where this series takes place
boom gotcha and of course the missing
artist in Hoboken is referring to Adam
now part of me is keeping tabs on these
other topics like the UFO and missing
Travelers because they're bound to come
back up or maybe maybe I'm just sipping
too much of lottie's tea anyway Misty
was right about them missing something a
fellow citizen detective discovers
Adam's credit card statement and it all
but confirms that he had a secret lady
friend in his life that being Shawna
down vote but you on the other hand can
like And subscribe to keep up to date on
all of the yellow jackets spoilers as
we're going to be covering all of this
top to bottom getting back into it Cali
and her boyfriend Kyle watched the
infamous Johnny Bananas backpack episode
of the real world Road Rules well over a
decade this clip just keeps popping up
but Cali knows Shawna did something to
Adam because of the news story at the
end of season one but the Shocker to her
is that Jeff her father knows and
seemingly everything is sunshine and
rainbows between the couple which is
starting a rift between them and Cali
back to the Wilderness we get a glimpse
of what Shawna is up to hanging out in
the meat locker with Jackie hold up hold
up this frigid friend is still alive oh
no no she she's dead never mind Shauna
is having severe hallucinations and
denial seemingly hanging out with Jackie
like nothing has happened so we can
assume that exposure and hunger is
ramping up the hallucinations this
season the two play the childhood game
of mash determining one another's
Futures which surprisingly almost picks
everything that Shauna actually has when
she's an adult aside from the million
dollars and rabbit pet the this could
actually refer to the rabbit that she
killed and then cooked and fed her
family we learn it's been two months
since Jackie has passed so Shauna is not
taking it well three new girls are
finally introduced probably being the
sacrificial meet this season but I just
have to kind of laugh because like where
were they the entire first season but
like now they're here I'm nitpicking but
crystal is one of them being a theater
kid singing and humming but getting on
everyone's nerves I wasn't singing I was
coming cool
stop back in the meat shed which was my
college dorm room name we learn more
about Jeff and Shauna and how their
relationship started it basically
started with lies she thought Jackie and
Jeff were on the relationship rocks but
in reality Jeff was going to leave
Jackie because she just wasn't putting
out for him so the Shauna and Jeff
situation started on false pretenses
which makes everything a bit more muddy
from everyone's point of view Shauna
upset about her own thoughts shoves
Jackie breaking off her ear frantically
trying to fix it instead picking it up
and placing it in her pocket now this
could be setting up the end of this
episode but an ear spiritually signifies
the reception of Truth Shauna learning
the true story from Jackie she returns
to the other stating that she had a cut
back on rations once again because food
is running dangerously low and uh stick
around because I think I know the
solution here tacio winning the state
senate campaign last season is far from
in the clear because Simone her wife is
pissed off about the basement altar even
though Tasia hasn't a clue what she's
talking about this was done because of
her sleepwalking and dirt eating which
by the way is probably Pika an eating
disorder in which people eat things that
usually are not considered food brought
upon by stress and other factors she
tried to surprise their son with a new
Pooch named Steve but she's not
permitting Tasia to see him until she
steps down from office and gets some
help so almost another blackmailing
situation here with her own family
threatening to go to the presses if it
isn't fixed seems awfully suspicious for
a setup of Simone going bye-bye and
Tasia covering it up but later she does
discover what she did in the basement in
is hella emotional about their old dog
biscuit and the potential danger she was
putting her family
so she may actually seek help because of
the overwhelming campaign and new
political position we find out Natalie
and Travis have been going on daily hunt
trips almost regularly returning without
any game resulting in a cutback of the
rations but while out hunting they've
been venturing in completely different
directions therefore creating and
mapping out a seven mile radius around
the cabin one thing jumped out to me
when looking at this makeshift map but
this looks to be the same hollow tree
stump that Lottie had sacrificed the
bear heart 2 at the end of season one
and it looks like it might say Gathering
Spot next to it I could be wrong maybe
everyone knows about the weird Lottie
rituals at the end of season one or
maybe that hasn't happened yet this
actually was a time Jump so we'll we'll
see the other reason the two have been
venturing out so much is to find Javi
Travis's younger brother ran off the
night of Dooms coming which was roughly
two months ago and they haven't seen a
glim items or any evidence of his fate
it's a total mystery at this point the
hallucinations probably due to
starvation continue with Travis
believing that a dead fox is a dead
hobby with Natalie quickly shaking him
back to his senses Natalie marks the
area with a small piece of fabric to
denote which areas they've already
explored now I have a feeling that this
could come back at some point or could
even be the meaning for the weird
symbols in the forest like the symbols
are the equivalent of Natalie leaving
fabric behind maybe the mysterious cabin
man from the end of season 1 was using
them as guide signs Misty was right
about them missing something Beyond
Adam's credit card statements because
Shauna remembers Adam had a mysterious
Art Studio that could contain something
incriminating her and Jeff saunter over
there to discover dozens of paintings of
Shauna taking a note from Jack Dawson's
book despite her never posing for him
obviously this is a weird predict
recommend for Jeff but full on turns
into a kink filled Passion Party pervert
Fest as the two make some Jackson
Pollock paintings of their own now there
is this hella creepy skull looking
painting that's featured a couple of
times it's not connected with anything
Supernatural from the Wilderness 25
years ago but I think it's Adam's
interpretation of Shauna having a darker
side to her all of the other paintings
are solely based on her beauty while
this is Sinister looking back in season
one we learned that Adam started doing
his own research on Shauna the yellow
jackets the crash everything making me
think that he came to the conclusion
that there might be a darker side to her
and this is unveiling The Mask to see
her True Colors the pair destroy the
paintings with turpentine rinse their
hands of the situation
hopefully Misty is on the hunt for
Natalie visiting the scummy motel for
answers Misty again continues to be my
favorite character solely based on the
unhinged nature of her bright and bubbly
but Sinister personality threatening the
hotel manager with all of his personal
information this freaks him out despite
stonewalling her revealing Natalie yes
had paid in cash and left in the middle
of the evening which is half true
citizen detective Misty discovers the
door appears to have been kicked in and
there was a security camera facing the
door so I'm thinking next episode she
will know exactly who took Natalie even
though Jeff got down with shawna's
sensual painting session he is a bit
torn on the whole situation aggressively
rocking out to Papa roach's Last Resort
thinking he may be Shauna's Last Hope or
that this is the final straw because the
creepy painting once again and makes an
appearance here meaning Jeff may be seen
Shauna for who she actually is for once
Jeff being rattled is also witnessed at
the dinner table when he is unable to
come up with a joke whereas earlier it
was no problem how do you get an art
major on your front porch
porch pay for the pizza what the buttons
say to the hot dog
yeah nothing
the pear burned Adam's license and
Shauna's Diaries disaster averted well
maybe back in the wilderness Natalie
tries to reason with Travis about Javi
which results in him having a panic
attack I believe that this is in fact
solely a panic attack and Lottie is able
to soothe him back into relaxing
similarly to the patient in the opening
sequence however with him having visions
of the stump heart sacrifice altar
screams Lottie may actually have some
sort of Supernatural power over the
others maybe Travis didn't actually see
this and the viewers us as viewers are
the only ones meant too either way I
think Lottie is only half right about
her Visions telling Travis Javi is alive
even though this is unknown she's trying
to use hope to keep him going so this
Lottie and the Lottie of the future
could honestly be hacks and delusional
for their own faux Powers Natalie though
is on to her which leads into present
day and her being kidnapped we finally
see who kidnapped her and yes the
inkling suspicion was lottie's cult and
that proves to be true as a young
recruit dressed in the same purple
coloring and sporting a similar pendant
with the symbol from the Wilderness
above the bed is a sign stating breathe
which we've seen you know used a couple
times on Travis and the patient in the
opening Natalie though stabs the recruit
with a fork escapes and learns she's at
a place called Camp green pine which
seems to be the same location Lottie was
giving her speech in the opening with
several other purple clad people chasing
her down Natalie stumbles into a
mid-summer like ceremony Lottie and the
others are partaking in wearing animal
masks referring back to the Wilderness
and our Primal State essentially burying
someone I want to say that this
symbolizes them shedding their old self
and being born again tying in with
lottie's speech in the opening Natalie
is ready to smash in lottie's brain but
stops her saying that she has a message
from Travis which causes her to freeze
interactions now I'm saying that she may
have a message because of her
involvement with emptying Travis's bank
accounts after his death but I also see
this as false hope the same potential
false hope she gave to Travis in the
wilderness about Javi Lottie knows
exactly what she's doing she's amassed
all of these followers because of the
same promise of hope the ending of the
episode sort of has a three-part story
playing out one of which is Cali finally
having her suspicions of her mother and
Adam being confirmed that they are
responsible for his disappearance
because of a burnt piece of his license
is found in the grill huge Rift between
the parents and Offspring this season
just wait Natalie and Travis on the
other hand following their usual routes
going out searching come across a dead
tree but it looks like the bass and Moss
around it is unaffected by the harsh
cold to me this looks similar to where
Lottie sacrificed the bear heart at the
end of season one but this is more of a
tree than a stump maybe whatever
sacrifice is causing this to actually
grow once again now this Moss also shows
up in the opening on the cabin so maybe
whatever Lottie sacrifices to is keeping
them safe or the evil from it is slowly
creeping into the rest of them lastly
the episode comes to a close on the
Grand Daddy of all setups Shauna is the
first to eat human flesh she had kept
Jackie's discarded ear in her pocket
throughout this whole episode longingly
looking at it a couple of times it could
be said she was doing this because she
was missing her friend but rather I
think she was weighing the options on
whether or not to eat it which she does
at the end setting us on a path of
full-on cannibalistic Coalition no doubt
Shawna is going to be the one that leads
them them all to eating human flesh with
her divvying out the rations Jackie is
slowly but surely going to become a menu
item for the rest of the girls it's it's
right there so I wonder if this divide
we see in the intro draws its Origins
back to this event with some doing
anything and everything to survive While
others refuse these practices this has
got to be why show runner Ashley Lyle
has called season two the winter of
their discontent it's also crazy that
this episode is titled friends Romans
and countrymen coming from the opening
line of a William Shakespeare monologue
or Billy shakes for all you cool kids
out there and the next few words of this
monologue are lend me your ears AKA
Jackie's ear
another thing I picked up on was
Natalie's relationship with Lottie and
her cult obviously last season Natalie
was kidnapped by them and the recruit of
this episode says we we were scared you
may hurt yourself this insinuates they
know of Natalie's destructive Behavior
well I think it's because the rehab
center Natalie graduated from in episode
1 of season one is owned by Lottie or
maybe Rehabilitation is actually what
this quote cult is the reason I say this
is because of the color of the clothing
worn Lottie the one in charge is wearing
orange in the opening with the others
wearing purple in Natalie's rehab she is
wearing purple while the counselor is
wearing a similar orange Lottie didn't
want Natalie to relapse so this is why
she was kidnapped but I think that there
might be more to this anyway that is
episode 1 of season two ending this
latest yellow jackets on a big ew
honestly I I think this is a great start
to this season building upon all of the
scrambles the characters are in while
introducing more survivors we didn't
know about in season one my biggest
question though is whether or not
Supernatural elements are actually at
play here a lot of the stuff can be
explained away via hallucinations and
science so I hope that they continue to
tow this line but what are your thoughts
on season two so far and what sort of
theories do you have Brewing about
anything and everything I'd love to hear
them in the comments and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
the Superman collection on the 15th of
April and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop your thoughts on episode 1 of
Yellowjackets we picked the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other
videos right over there great throwback
breakdowns we've been doing but with all
of that out of the way thank you for
your constant support this is episode
one we're gonna be breaking all of these
down I've been Jared I'll see you in the
next one take care and peace